what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four because I told you guys
that we weren't done even though we had
that epic moment that happened the
ending of this comic I'm excited to see
how you guys respond because it's
amazing so of course this picks up in
the immediate aftermath of the great big
huge epic moment that we just saw adult
Franklin Richards basically making
galactus's Herald and then fighting the
mad celestials right it was just
ridiculously awesome now of course
Valeria Richards ever the Sourpuss and
the Fantastic Four Comics is really kind
of giving us this monologue of
everything that had gone on talking
about Franklin Richards facing off
against the celestials and the whole
thing with Galactus and she really is
just kind of irritated at the fact that
while it was all going down she wasn't
really doing anything she was just kind
of sitting there watching it all happen
the truth about Valeria is that as a kid
and any parent who knows this will
probably tell you kids are egocentric
they think the universe revolves around
them right the whole world revolves
around them but one of the things that
she kind of talks about really muses to
herself is she doesn't really like her
old herself she feels like there's
something off about her and her older
self is just kind of like right back at
you kid like I don't really like you
either uh there really isn't a major
thing going on here but it is kind of a
funny moment the other part about this
is that you have kid Franklin talking to
his older self the conversation between
the two of them is really really cool
because like Franklin of course
approaches it from a kid's perspective
right what would you do if you were a
little kid and your future self showed
up and basically crushed like some
celestials you'd be amazed by it right
you'd be like we totally crushed those
space gods and I've got a beard is it
itchy and of course adult Franklin is
just like yes it is because even with
all my Powers I can't solve the one
thing that plagues all men everywhere an
itchy beard no he does uh he does his
beard doesn't itch
but in reality that's why I don't really
keep a beer too much man because that
damn thing itches like you wouldn't
believe but the thing about this is that
of course he asked like can I call you
Mr Franklin and that's when the response
of his older self is yes as long as I
can call you kid Franklin so for those
of you guys who are always wondering
where the moniker or nickname for
Franklin Richards came from and people
calling him kid Franklin this is it and
that's how that works when it comes to
Marvel Comics for those of you guys who
are unfamiliar with it usually there's
just kind of a colloquial name for a
character that just takes hold and
everybody just starts calling them that
it's just sort of the way those things
work and so of course the funny thing is
he asked him he's like can I tell you a
secret and his older self is like yeah
sure and younger Franklin kid Franklin
is like I always wanted my my own
Galactus and of course his older self is
like yes I know now this is a cool
moment because one of the things that
we've always talked about when it comes
to Jonathan Hickman is that he's very
much on building things up right the
idea of Franklin always having wanted
his own Galactus that comes to Bear In
Secret Wars if you guys remember that
story with your Jonathan Hickman there
was a point where literally Franklin
just sits in galactus's helmet right
he's like he has his own Galactus that's
how this works right that's where this
comes from so it's the small little
things that Jonathan Hickman always
brings back in his story sometimes it
serves no major plot point it's just an
offhanded remark that a character made
at some point along the line and it's
really just a nice little moment to be
like I remember that when Franklin said
he wanted his own Galactus he finally
has it right and it's like it's a cool
thing right it's just a a cool little
thing that goes on there and so of
course following this what ends up
happening is that while now it's time
for cleanup Duty right basically heading
back to New York getting the city all
sorted out Galactus approaches Franklin
Richards so while everybody ends up
taking off to the city of New York adult
Franklin stays behind now this leads to
one of the most important conversations
between the two and if you've ever read
anything about adult Franklin Richards
you have heard of this conversation
happening that as Franklin and Galactus
are basically spending time with each
other just kind of hanging out there
Galactus sort of Muses and says what one
day it will all end right Sons will die
and worlds will wither as the universe
begins to cool the heat death of the
everything for so long I have thought I
would face it by myself and Franklin
responds and saying but now you know
better he says I will be there standing
beside you we will watch as all that has
been will become something new the birth
of a new universe he says still [ __ ] up
big guy we've got billions of years
until we have to worry about that of
course Franklin is Immortal now there's
been a couple instances in Marvel Comics
when really Marvel is just sort of
brought back the idea of Franklin's
immortality a great example of this is
during Hickman's Avengers The New
Avengers run when Captain America is
whisked Through Time by the time Stone
of course he ends up in the future
basically at the end of all things where
he's brought below Kane the Conqueror
and his alter egos immortus and uh and
iron lad and they basically say like
everything has to end there's no
conceivable way for you to stop up the
collapse of the Multiverse so to make
sure you don't screw up the time stream
we're gonna hold you here of course
Captain America ends up escaping anyway
and there's nothing Kang or immortus or
iron lad can do if you're really excited
about that we do have a playlist with
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers on
it because we've remastered Fantastic
Four we'll likely combine these into a
new remastered full story so you can
kind of go forward and enjoy it and it's
in its modern form but the thing about
this is that Franklin's immortality came
to bear when Captain America was whisked
through time and encountered Franklin
Richards thousands of years into the
future and Franklin still he looks just
like this right now the cool thing about
that is Galactus chimes in and says I
dreaded feared the return of solitude of
being alone forever I never imagined
this is what you would become now this
is a great moment because one of the
things to know about Franklin's history
is over the years in Marvel Comics his
vast reality warping Powers started off
innocuous right it was the old Fantastic
Four story which I think was an issue
145 I'm not going to swear to it but
it's the one where Franklin's playing
with a Rubik's Cube he gets frustrated
there's a commercial on the TV that says
why don't you just grow up and he
subconsciously ages himself into an
adult by using his reality warping
Powers it was the first time we'd really
seen him use his powers on that level
after that it just got bigger and
grander so then you go into like Heroes
Reborn when Franklin Richards resurrects
basically all the heroes who died
fighting Onslaught he resurrects him
from the dead and then places them in a
pocket universe that he created that he
carries around in the form of a ball of
course they're all brought back during
Hero's Return but then you go into the
abraxa Saga where he resurrects galatus
from the dead the first time so it's one
of these things where over the years in
Marvel Galactus has actually watched
Franklin he's watched the things he's
done and he's seen what he's capable of
but he had never really imagined that
Franklin Richards would be able to
achieve this level of power and it's not
so much what Franklin Richards did here
this Galactus combining the sum total of
all things that Franklin has done and
the analysis is this that the Mad
celestials came up with which is that
he's beyond omega level the reality and
depending on how you want to slice it
Galactus and Franklin are equal in power
but there are stories that have been
done that have indicated that Franklin
is actually Beyond Galactus in terms of
power that he's more powerful than
Galactus is and so of course Franklin in
response to galata's statement simply
says well you'll have to wait a little
longer Union occurs further down the
road so the idea is that when the
universe collapses and it dies and then
it explodes with a big bang into a new
universe that Galactus and Franklin will
be the two last living things in
existence they will merge and they'll be
reborn as a new cosmic entity that's a
combination of both now of course once
they all get back to New York City while
the Fantastic Four do clean up their
mess they do a kind of unceremoniously
they open a portal to the negative Zone
and basically all the stuff that's been
destroyed and all the cars that have
been trashed just get thrown into the
negative zone so literally they're just
stuffing everything into a Multiverse
will closet more or less and it's kind
of funny to see because of course the
Baxter building is reconstituted and in
fact it's modified a little bit so that
the younger kids in the future
foundation because they're composed of
like different races or different parts
of the world that they all have their
own individual habitat where they can
basically reside and live in a kind of
comfort right so it's cool to see that
it's been modified in that capacity now
of course the next thing that goes on is
they all basically take off into space
because what's happened is that Reed
Richards and them have created something
called the foundation right the orbital
space station education facility in
geosynchronous orbit above the Baxter
building basically meaning that as the
Earth rotates it rotates with it and
it's always directly above the Baxter
building in Marvel Comics so it's
actually a cool little thing like a
direct satellite but this is where
they'll receive a lot of their education
and so following this what you end up
doing is having the Fantastic Four
dealing with Valeria now this is a
really really cool moment here because
what goes on is that before adult
Franklin turns that as Valeria is
talking to the Fantastic Four they're
like okay we need to have a conversation
right Reed and Susan are like we need to
have a conversation and one of the
things that had gone on of course as you
guys notice over the course of this run
there was a lot of Deceit being
performed or being done by Valeria she
was lying to people tricking people and
all of it was done in service of a
greater cause but the point that Reed
and Susan are hitting at is this cannot
be a regular thing of course Ben Grimm
chimes in is just kind of like nobody
likes bad girls kiddo and then Johnny of
course is like well I mean you know like
I mean it ain't always the case been
sometimes bad girls are good you know
like but of course it's a funny thing
because she ultimately makes a promise
where she tells them yes no more secrets
I won't hide anything from you anymore
wrong because here's what happens if you
guys recall right when everything was
popping off and you had like the Mad
celestials who were still on the other
side of the portal before they had
arrived to Earth that you had this
moment where they were basically doc Dr
Doom was going to keep the one or going
to be the one that would basically buy
them time so they could get to the
portal on the other side and close the
portal off Dr Doom still trapped over
there right he's still trapped there
what Valeria had told him is she said
find a way Uncle doom find a way to stay
alive there's something in there
something that's worth the cost of you
stepping in and buying his time it's why
Doctor Doom did this he literally stayed
here because there's a benefit to it and
so were the Mad celestials were more
focused on incapacitating Doom because
they didn't really see him as like a
credible threat they effectively knocked
him out as soon as he was done they
focused on trying to find a way through
the portal because that was their main
effort right I mean literally time was
taking the portal was closing right so
it was really more of just running out
of time as opposed to like this guy
doctor Doom's annoying let's just kill
him right now right in Doom's powerful
enough to be able to hold off celestials
even if not outright destroy them but
because he survived he makes his way he
makes his way through the Citadel of
Doom you guys remember at the very
beginning of the story when we learned
about the Council of reads what they
were doing the Citadel is not totally
destroyed right Dr Doom finds one of the
seats on the throne right the three
seats that were held by those different
versions of Reed he ends up
reconstituting or at least taking out
the other two seats he has one for
himself and that's it and as he sits
down he puts on one of the infinity
gauntlets he picks up one of the swords
and then out of nowhere he sees someone
ask the question doom and that's
literally when all these lobotomized Dr
Dooms start ascending out of the rubble
and literally just kind of like
worshiping Doctor Doom himself and as
they start shouting his name Doctor Doom
is like yes and he just sits down on the
throne surrounded by those who would
worship him as a God and simply says
here I can build with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end the parliament of Doom has arisen
thank you all for watching and I will
we'll catch you all later peace